hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
ah
[Music]
i'm just checking in on you seeing how
your how the [ __ ] is your
week going huh right now
okay if you get to punch one person in
the face what's the first face that just
popped into your head yeah what punch
would you throw
what would you like their reaction to be
if you have quick
answers to all of these questions you
are working the wrong job and over the
next
hour i'm gonna tell you how to make your
dreams come true
so you don't drive to work thinking
about punching someone in the [ __ ]
face
i love that [ __ ] over the next hour i'm
gonna [ __ ]
act like i'm gonna tell you something
while i'm really not and eventually
there's gonna be a [ __ ] link
i know this is going to cost money
because what you're claiming
is ridiculous so just show me the link
you know since the beginning of time
people have been trying to lose weight
that statement makes no sense they were
trying to gain weight it was caveman
days i don't give a [ __ ] it's
advertising
there's been all kinds of exercise
equipment and [ __ ] this and [ __ ]
that
but what happens you end up putting the
weight right back down well you know
what over the next
hour i'm gonna tell you the secret
that all these hollywood celebrities all
of these ufc shredded guys
all of these [ __ ] skinny ass
supermodels that do it
it's called chew and spit now
[ __ ] with you um i am in a great mood
i'm in a great mood baby
i am i uh i've been working out
now i didn't reach my goal of getting
down to 186 pounds i missed it by a
pound
all right is it it's it's
what am i gonna quit huh am i going to
take my sneakers off
walk out of the gym with my head down
wearing my socks
as i hear people in the background like
hey where are you going
game's not over yet
whatever i'm [ __ ] i'm on it
the world has no place for a fat ginger
or maybe they want one but i'm not
filling the void
you ain't getting this pasty [ __ ] not
today baby not tomorrow either
um yeah it worked out today and i felt
[ __ ] great you know going to vegas
[ __ ] me up a little bit like it does for
most people
and then it took me a couple days
getting back to get back on the horse
which is today wednesday
all right and i'm making a comeback
the same way the montreal canadiens
refused to get swept all right tampa
all right you're up three games to none
all right you 18 million dollars over
the salary cap
but for some reason that's not
considered a [ __ ] cheating advantage
there's all these [ __ ] articles
saying oh what they did isn't cheating
it's [ __ ] brilliant
that guy had a legit hip injury oh yeah
and he and then he comes back the first
game of the playoffs
you know okay if that is not
manipulating a [ __ ] system that isn't
[ __ ] cheating
but letting a cunt's hair worth the air
out of a football is i don't think i
want to be a sports fan anymore
um yeah i'm actually kind of rooting for
the canadians now that i know that these
[ __ ] [ __ ] are 18 million dollars
over the [ __ ] cap and it's legal
they didn't do anything wrong
this guy actually wrote an article just
saying you're just being a jealous [ __ ]
it's like no no i'm not because i
watched my team get raked over the coals
every [ __ ] time somebody came out and
i don't know
turned a fan on those on the [ __ ]
sidelines
i saw my team people would just make
[ __ ] up and espn would run with it
for years that whole [ __ ] oh they
tape recorded the practice
it was complete [ __ ] [ __ ] and
those [ __ ] [ __ ]
at espn did their retraction at like one
in the morning
three years later was not covered
then meanwhile i'm supposed to sit here
and be like oh okay
all right so you figured out a way a
legal way that you can be 18 million
dollars
over the cap and you're not cheating so
then in the same way
these people that have offshore accounts
you know throughout the [ __ ] whatever
the caribbean or the canary islands and
they go from one island to another which
is a different
country and they grease the bankers and
the lawyers and everybody
and politicians and every one of those
islands
you know like you make a zillion dollars
and then this company that doesn't exist
and barbados [ __ ] builds you for a
zillion dollars and then this other
company builds that company for a
billion dollars in a different island
and so on and so forth so they get to
the last [ __ ] island
and then the last island then lo
that company that doesn't exist that
build that other company that other
company
that doesn't really [ __ ] exist then
gives you the money back in the form of
a loan
which is not taxable and you're gonna
air quote
pay the loan back but guess what the the
company
for no good goddamn reason forgives the
loan
and that's how you live tax-free
totally [ __ ] legal
so what am i supposed to say with that
that's not cheating all right
go [ __ ] yourself and [ __ ] the canary
island [ __ ] tampa bay lightning
oh his hips all better just in time for
the playoffs i'm actually rooting for
the canadians
that'd be great watch him come back
the ultimate loss and i felt it too as a
bruins fan the [ __ ] goddamn filthy
flyers came back
i remember that uh uh gagne simone gagne
came back and crazy went down with an
injury we have three games and none lead
and that just disappeared
and i remember watching game seven
in this club that was sort of like a
dance club and a bar
and there was about [ __ ] 40 hardcore
bruins fans out in the back patio in
silence
watching us lose that last [ __ ] game
um
i'm wishing that on tampa bay and i'm a
bruins fan too
all right and it's not because yeah i
don't
you're gonna [ __ ] give my patriots
all of that [ __ ] [ __ ] and not
give them their [ __ ] do
as they dominated the league for two
goddamn decades
and every [ __ ] hangnail you could
find you're trying to [ __ ]
and then these [ __ ] could be 18 million
oh actually you know if you look at it
it's not yet right is that what you're
gonna say i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] because i got the
endorphins flowing through me
an elliptical an old man's best friend
it's like you're running but you're not
hitting the pavement
you're wearing out your hips but who
gives a [ __ ] whatever i'll get hip
surgery
you know and then i won't do the road
and i'll come back
the night of my special
to collect all that streaming money um
anyway um i'm [ __ ] with the tampa
light but not really
uh oh is it legal did they find a
loophole
was it genius i mean that tax evasion is
[ __ ] genius
i mean that's a ton of [ __ ] work
there's so much work involved
figuring out who the [ __ ] you have to
pay off in each goddamn country
that i in a way i mean it'd be easier
just to write a check to the [ __ ]
federal reserve you know which isn't
really a federal
entity which is a private corporation
who takes everybody's [ __ ] money
including the governments got us all on
the hook but you know
they're not they found a loophole
they found a loophole
um the phoenix suns your phoenix suns
with the gorilla mascot that has never
made sense but is still one of the best
mascots in the league
i gotta look it up why a gorilla is is
is i almost said
roger paul chris paul roger paul is the
first guy that i sent a tape to in new
york city
that told me i had a future i still
remember it
he said hey bill this is roger paul i
sent him a vhs
tape i just got your tape of me killing
at dick doherty's room at the grill 93
in
uh andover massachusetts i believe 93
north
it's one of the great stand-up rooms i
was ever in so everybody killed there so
you would tape so i wrote
tape there and i sent it down to this
guy roger paul
and he said bill i saw your tape you
have a major career
ahead of you he called it he knew he
knew someday i'd be in the middle of a
[ __ ] coveted
thing standing next to a [ __ ] highway
screaming my jokes at people inside of
cars he saw it he saw the major career
no i'm kidding
um but i i saved that message on my
answer machine and listened to it like a
thousand [ __ ] times
i still remember all those early ones i
remember louis veranda
you know the great tomato gardener that
he is
at caroline's comedy i still remember
his thing he's like billy
this is uh louis veranda from caroline's
i saw your tape you're very funny
that's what i did it was all sort of
like in a riddle
sort of form i'd like to see you at my
club
remember that i was just i was sitting
in my
railroad walk-through bedroom apartment
on the upper east side
screaming in silence like yes
it's all happening
um anyway chris paul not roger paul
roger paul who booked me on one of my
first road dates when i first got
i never even told him this [ __ ] he
booked me in some room and [ __ ]
way up there in vermont way the [ __ ] up
i just remember he got on 87
and right like the last time was he i do
you seriously want to go drive to canada
right now
that was your exit and then you [ __ ]
went over the river into [ __ ]
vermont and i worked with this [ __ ]
passive-aggressive [ __ ]
um i was a young kid and he was like 10
15 years older than me and i was
headlining and he wasn't so right there
there's gonna be friction but he acted
like he was my friend
so this [ __ ] [ __ ] was supposed to do
20 minutes
the first show he did
35.
so i kind of said to him oh sorry i
didn't know where the light was
and i was like all right and then the
next show he did 37.
she had one show friday and two on
saturday or something like that and all
i remember
was he just kept saying oh sorry you
would talk to me and all that [ __ ] and
then on the last
[ __ ] show because he what he was
trying to do was wear out the crowd
he did 50 [ __ ] minutes
50 [ __ ] minutes this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] who i never saw again
i never saw him again and i went up
there i was so [ __ ] mad at him and
then i had to do 45
after he had totally burnt out the crowd
and they were they were hammered that
was
that was what happened when you were
coming up and
you know this was the early to midnight
mid 90s so this was a guy who's probably
headlining in the 80s
and then he dipped down um
and it became my fault that he didn't
get where he wanted to be during
the comedy boom and now it was like a
lull so but that's not what i want to
talk i want to talk to you about chris
paul who might i believe would get his
first ring
all right uh they win game one
was it 118 to 108 or something like that
uh i'm hoping it's going to be
a good series uh giannis oh god i had it
right last night
ante de cumpo uh i don't watch enough
hoop
um was playing last night which was
great
i know he's not 100 with this deep but
i'm hoping that it'll be a nice classic
game seven i'm thinking the last [ __ ]
time
you know the phoenix suns in the bucks
were like two powerhouses that had been
the 1970s
you know than the first half like 70 to
um even though i know charles barkley
led to phoenix sons
i mentioned that last night in 1993 they
went to the nba finals so um
i am and it's the finals it's the
stanley cup final
it's the nba finals
um so i'm gonna be watching that
and uh i may be watching tonight i'm
going to be watching hopefully
the canadians win another game
you know what i mean and gradually
have the greatest comeback in stanley
cup final
history i am now rooting for them
as a bruins fan which i cannot [ __ ]
believe because no one
before i found out they were 18 million
over the cap
was rooting hard every every round i've
been rooting against these [ __ ] guys
because i want the curse of patrick
wah to continue because that's all i got
okay and all canadians fans i have is
hey you remember
last century when i was 30 years younger
and we used to win it you know
i mean if you go back 45 years we used
to win it all the [ __ ] time
that's all they got like
their theme song is that bruce
springsteen song glory days
they'll pass you by glory days
when you're booing patrick why you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i want to do that so bad but now i i
can't all right it's got to be a fair
fight here
it's got to be a fair fight so
congratulations to tampa you figured out
a way
to uh you know have an extra superstar
more than everybody else
congratulations um
anyway uh i watched that race
the last f1 race i had a great time
watching that
max verstappen winning it uh
botos coming in second i forget who came
in third but all i know is a certain
[ __ ] guy was not even on the podium
so i can't even imagine
and i was waiting for them for stop it
winston lewis hamilton is in fourth
oh he must he must be so upset
i mean fourth place he probably went
home listening to drake
um but i
love i'm not rooting against lewis
hamilton i i'm i'm just teasing the guy
the guy's [ __ ] amazing he's an
amazing driver
um but i love that mercedes can't figure
out their [ __ ] car right now because
it's making it really exciting because
i'll tell you right now
the genius of how much lewis hamilton
sulks
when he's not winning is like he
puts the mercedes team of engineers
they're like the husband in the
relationship
okay and mama bear isn't happy you know
the deal when your wife isn't happy
everybody's gonna stop what the [ __ ]
they're doing to try to make her happy
or else we're not gonna be able to enjoy
our [ __ ] day so i think that that's
what's going on
so he's gonna be so [ __ ] he's gonna
be moodier than a [ __ ]
nba superstar that doesn't feel he has
enough [ __ ] free agent help
to get a layup super uh uh [ __ ] nba
championship
so i think that that's gonna drive them
no pun intended
to uh give him a better car
at which point we're going to see some
racing man
um which would be tremendous because i
got to be honest with you
other than watching lewis hamilton in
fourth place was kind of a [ __ ]
boring race
because now max verstappen is you know
his car is so fast it's a race to turn
one and once he's out there he's in the
clean air it's [ __ ] over again
um but whatever i'm not gonna sit here
and [ __ ] because
it's been the lewis hamilton show
forever so uh it's fun to see somebody
else in there it's fun to see the suns
and the bucks in the finals
you know and it'd be fun to see the
canadians win [ __ ] three straight
fourth street i know i'm a [ __ ] what do
you want from me
what do you want from me um
anyway i'm still flying high off of the
[ __ ] uh
the trip out to vegas i had such a just
to be back to finally making some
[ __ ] money
you know um i've always been good with
my money but last year you know like
everybody else i lost money first time
[ __ ]
since uh way back in my roger paul days
when i was uh hemorrhaging cash
[ __ ] eating pasta every night afraid
to take a taxi sometimes i would walk
home so i i wouldn't [ __ ] you know
just to save a subway token this back
when new york was a lot scarier and i
did that like one time like what am i
doing
i think it was uh
i think i want to say was it 75 cents
and then it went up to a dollar 25 and
everybody flipped out
let me just see 1995
price of a nyc subway
token was it 75 cents
oh wow look at this they actually sell
these tokens used on ebay for 12 dollars
last version of the token oh is dollar
fifty fair
oh so it went from 125 to 150.
yeah i mean i was spending like three
bucks
and i was like you know three bucks you
know it was like chinese food for a week
no at the transit museum store you can
buy a set of
the five historic new york city subway
tokens introduced in 1953
1970 1980 1986 and 1995
as well as subway tokens made into key
rings
lapel pins cufflinks bracelets and money
clips
that's actually kind of cool the 1953
token they got this and this this is on
gothammagazine.com the 1970 token
1980 i don't recognize any of these 1986
nothing
1995 token oh yeah it looked like a
the yen because it had the hole in the
middle of it which i don't even remember
that
it was a dollar and 86.
it was 60 cents in 1980
30 cents in 1970
in 15 cents in 1953 and that's the way
it was on the new york city subways
wait how old are the subways what were
they was it free
history okay
first subway nyc year
1904 the first underground line of the
subway
opened on october 27th 1904
um almost 36 years after the opening the
first
elevated line new york city all right
new york city subway
rapid transit system all right
so it began in 1904
construction expansion lines roots this
is actually really interesting to me
because i'm a nerd
fares here we go
riders pay a single fare to enter the
subway system and may transfer between
trains i know that
what did it what did it initially cost
the metrocad
what's the omni october 23rd was
announced that the metrocard be phased
out and replaced by
omni a contactless fair payment
system with the fair payment being
made using apple pay google pay
debit cards with near field
communication technology radio frequency
on them
so how did the homeless ride it now
i had no idea
all right this last thing i know this is
probably history
how much was a subway
ride in 1904
nyc
single ride costs five seconds say
mister can you spare a nickel son get
home to me mutter
and that's the way it was new york city
sorry all right let's uh let me read a
little advertising here and then i'll
tell you a couple more dumb stories
all right oh mack weldon everybody
kick off your summer kick your summer
off in style with the brand that's
reinventing
men's basics mac weldon weldon weldon
mac weldon's full collection includes
t-shirts polos buttons up
shorts pants who wears short shorts
pants swimwear and so much moa
with light and breathable fabric
technology mac weldon keeps you cool and
comfortable all summer
from work to working out happy hour to
playing with your kids
mac weldon has men's essentials for
whatever your day
includes dive into mac weldon's swim
line with trunk and board short
options that are quick to dry and have
four-way
stretch fabric that's amazing so when
you're running along the pool
no matter which way you go you won't
[ __ ] tear your ball back
when you're in the pool mack weldon's
new maverick tech
chino short and radius short are perfect
additions
to your summer wardrobe i'm gonna get
some of those i've been swimming lately
they'll keep you comfortable so you can
confidently power through most of your
active days
mack weldon also has a free loyalty
program
called weldon blue level one gets you
free shipping for life
once you reach level two by spending two
hundred dollars you get twenty percent
off every order for the next year
for twenty percent off your first order
visit mackweldon.com
slash burn and to enter the promo code
burr that's mack weldon m
a c w e l d o n
dot com promo code burr for 20
off mac weldon reinventing men's basics
oh look who's back everybody my
favorites here my bookie how the [ __ ]
you doing
in the world of sports the off season is
a time to relax and regroup
after a hard fought season but playing
with my bookie gives you the choice to
decide
out of the [ __ ] blue when your season
begins and ends
at mybookie.ag you can bet on hundreds
of games in leagues from around the
world
the world the world the world the world
whether it's a game day polly dude i got
a system
or a long shot winner sorry hope sorry
[ __ ] hope
my bookies got you covered if you're
looking for something to bet on look no
further than ufc 264
any highly anticipated rematch between
dustin
poirier poirier and conor mcgregor
mcgregor is currently listed as the
underdog in the fight and bets on
pourier
to win by ko would pay out nearly two to
one
regardless of whether you're backing
pourier or mcgregor this weekend take
advantage
of pre-fight props or bet the matches
live
to shift the odds in your favor and come
out on top
sign up today at mybookie.ag use promo
code bur
and you'll receive up to one thousand
dollar bonus dollar
dollars in bonus money when you make
your first deposit that's a thousand
bucks in extra cash
when you make your first deposit with my
bookie using promo code bur
at mybookie.ag but anything anytime
anywhere
with my bookie what do you guys think
about that fight this weekend
i mean i always love seeing new blood
coming in there but like yeah i don't
want to [ __ ]
i don't want to see conor mcgregor lose
again
am i crazy i'm root for mcgregor
ghana mcgregor you know i hope he wins
and then retires
i don't want to see that guy get all
[ __ ] knocked out and then
[ __ ] up and everything and then i
don't then you know what i hate when
somebody like somebody great
gets beaten is in all these other people
that are too much of a [ __ ] to [ __ ]
go into a ring or never even had a fight
in their life get to talk [ __ ]
like i love watching this fight why do
you love watching the fight
because he's so much of a [ __ ] man
that you can't handle it that you want
to see him lose so you feel better about
yourself he's one of the greatest of all
[ __ ] time
that's like when uh what's-her-face loss
to uh holly holmes
dude what is going on with my brain i
can't remember anybody
i can't remember anybody's names
holly holmes ronda rousey
everybody talking all that [ __ ] about
ronda rousey ronda rousey
like put women fighting on
on the map
she came out of [ __ ] notes she used
to headline those [ __ ] fights
and on all the entertainment that she
gave you and then she gets knocked out
once and all these people are [ __ ]
excited yeah
[ __ ] you and all that [ __ ] i don't
understand that
i always have this i don't know the way
i look whenever i see that happen
even sometimes it'll be a fighter that i
didn't particularly care for there's
always
an element of sadness when i see a great
fighter get knocked out and then you
just have to respect the balls that they
have
to go in there knowing that that's going
to happen at any time
and they could they could actually have
you know
health issues for the rest of their life
with the punishment that they're taking
and then on top of all of that they got
to go on youtube and take [ __ ] from a
guy like me who hasn't had a fight since
the [ __ ] sixth grade it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous show the fight is some
[ __ ] respect
so either way i'm hoping for a great
fight and um
i know the younger kid has a huge you
know
future ahead of him so i got i got a
roof for the underdog
um in that fight so i will be watching
say
night i will absolutely be watching so
um i've been working so hard you know
flying the choppers here trying to get
ready for my instrument which i'm
i swear to god it's like walking up to a
mountain like you keep thinking it's
right there and every time you take
another step it's like no it's another
hundred yards away
um i haven't been playing drums so
yesterday i was like i gotta sit down
and play these things before
i forget and sometimes taking like a
week off from something
is actually really good because you kind
of you forget what you were trying to do
you get out of your rut you're excited
to sit down
and um i've been watching a lot of like
drummers
that um rather than just
shredding on the drums you know crazy
chops
i'm trying to watch people that are
actually like saying something
and um their approach to the kit
versus somebody who learns a lick adds
their little thing to it and then you
know
gets it up to a zillion bpms and then
moves it around the kit
on all different sound sources so it's i
mean
i know it took me the longest time to
understand
that you know whatever the lick is right
it would be like i
said uh put it in the microwave
right if you just do the same lick all
around the
kit it's gonna sound like you're doing a
bunch of different [ __ ] but you're
really just going
put it in the microwave put it in the
microwave put it in the right way put it
away put it right away
you're just saying the same like a crazy
person where these people
that i'm watching conga players too and
everything how they kind of
they build like a vibe and there's
something about it that's so exciting
because you can tell
that something
an idea came into the head that made him
play something that then leads to
something else
like um that level of freedom
on the kit so i've just been kind of
experimenting at my pathetically low
level
i just sort of playing like doubles on
the snare and then adding an accent or
something and then throwing in a tom
and then like what that makes you think
of next and then can i play that
can i do a little double stroke roll
sing a fill
and then play whatever the [ __ ] phil i
just sang because you can always
you know sing something beyond
your playing ability so
it was funny [ __ ] and i just was having
a great time when i was in a great mood
and then i went to the you know the
bottom triplets
after that afterwards after i kind of
tried to like
i don't know how to connect with the
instrument as opposed to sitting down
i'm going to play paradiddles yesterday
i played them
at 90 bpms today i will try to get it up
to 91
bpms you know which there's something to
say about that if you're working on
technique but after a while
it it's just mind-numbingly uh
it's boring as opposed to trying to get
there where you could like
play something that makes you feel
something that that makes you then play
something and then all of a sudden
maybe on some low level you're actually
expressing yourself
through an instrument which to me is one
of the most exciting things i've ever
seen a human being do
um so
i don't know anyway with that uh we're
kind of out of time here uh
because i gotta go study i gotta go
study for this [ __ ] thing
my little simulator um all right that's
the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast uh
the great andrew females is going to
place a little bit of music little music
musical interlude and then uh we'll have
a
uh bonus bonus track no a bonus episode
of thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast
by the way have i told you guys that my
son i think i think he thinks my name is
ball
because he says my daughter's name he'll
say his mom would be like mama mama and
then i walk in and he's like ball
ball he looks at me and he says it when
i pick him up then he does look around
and look for a ball
and i got to tell you i'm [ __ ] loving
it
because nia has been saying to him going
dad dad that's dead
and he goes ball and i'm like yeah ball
you don't
you're gonna learn my name someday i
don't need to you're [ __ ] gravitating
towards sports but
and you're gonna be my little sports
buddy are you [ __ ] kidding me
you don't ever need to know my name so
i'm really excited about that
he also seems to like cars and [ __ ] it's
amazing
like having a kid it's like you you made
you made like a new friend
you know who also doesn't know what the
hell they're doing and you're kind of
responsible
as they walk towards stuff he he's
[ __ ] strong as hell
and you put him down and he just runs
out of the room
uh you got to make sure the doors are
closed this kid will make a break for it
like you can't believe and when you
chase him he thinks it's the funniest
thing ever
so of course you know i like making
people laugh so i just go i just go hey
hey where you going where you going he's
like he just runs down the hall
and when i pick him up he does the
cutest scream and laugh
ever it's just every it's every thing
you want to become a parent for
so i used to do that with this sister
and she cracks up now laughing because i
showed this video of me when i used to
do it with my daughter
and uh she thinks it's the coolest thing
ever that is funny now she wants me to
do it to her and she's like
a big kid now so um it's messing up my
back a little there
all right that's it i'll uh you guys
have a great weekend enjoy the music and
the uh the extra episode the throwback
episode all right yeah
[ __ ] i'll see you on monday
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
for monday um july 8th
how are you how is it going wow this
sounds really good to me
i hope it's sounding this good to you i
think i nailed it
what's up with these levels it's [ __ ]
phenomenal
some douche is now going to twitter me
or tweet me
whatever um actually i thought the uh
the treble was a little too high
oh so was your mother when she was
pregnant with you
you [ __ ] drunk fetal [ __ ] years later
just walking around criticizing people
and you know what it's not your fault
it's because your mother
first of all she was a [ __ ] spread her
legs no protection
all the leaves are brown leaves are
brown
and her legs are spread and her legs are
spread
oh i could sing that whole song and
annoy the [ __ ] out of you
[Laughter]
that's why i want to hear from next week
peoples whose mothers were [ __ ] and
they drank during pregnancies
i want to hear what you think about
world events that's what i want to hear
is that what you want to hear yeah it is
it is what i want to hear it's my
podcast
it is what i want to hear um
i'm loving twitter and i [ __ ] hate it
by the way i got to stop reading
comments there's always people [ __ ]
correcting you
you know i got this european tour coming
up and someone was saying
hey you're doing any of the uh smaller
cities and i was like no
just pretty much all i said all the
capitals and it was like 10 countries
and one [ __ ] country it wasn't the
capital and i got like 20 people
um actually the campbell scotland is not
glasgow
it's actually edinboro and they're
probably just being nice
they're probably actually in reality in
their heads when they were typing it
they were actually going like
i'm not trying to be a douche just let
you know it's not glasgow it's edinburgh
she's trying to help out this is just me
over here in the back
over here in my corner of the internet
just trying to help out that's probably
how they were typing it but i'm such a
negative douche
that i hear it in my head
[Music]
you know that's how i hear it that's
basically how i hear anybody telling me
that i'm doing anything wrong are you
like me isn't that exactly everybody all
of a sudden
no matter what language they're speaking
like some [ __ ] asian person
right or some asian [ __ ] right
to keep it clean
um call back to a special whenever the
[ __ ] i did that one
um came up to me and was speaking
oh god how dumb am i against this was if
he was up there speaking asian
if he was talking in his native language
korean whatever and it sounded like you
know
you know i thought that was that right i
would hear that
like that if he was talking to somebody
else but like if he felt i pulled into
his parking spot
it immediately would just be like oh
dora or your daughter
which is me it just immediately sounded
like this guy's a [ __ ]
you know even if i stole his spot
and even if i knew he was right and i
was wrong in the moment
i'm such a dick that i i would
i would i would block out that voice in
my head going you know this guy's right
this guy is right you know insulted him
a little bit a little bit
you know you kind of took his spot i
would still block that out
but the only thing that i can take
positive out of it
is as far as any sort of like level of
maturity that i have gained
throughout my adult life is uh i
at least now i recognize that i do that
and i i'm actually i've gotten good
enough that within 10 minutes
of actually whoever i just called the
[ __ ] and driving away i actually
kind of admit out loud on the card going
in the car to myself going like you know
that was right bill you kind of wear a
uh
you were kind of the douche so you know
i'm trying to get on your bad side but
just next time let's try to
you know try to hear the other person
try to apologize
um so anyways this is the monday morning
podcast
i like saying it that way this is the
monday morning podcast like when they
say the
ohio state university which is one of
the funniest bragging things
ever you're bragging about a state
school
when you [ __ ] up in high school and
you live in ohio
and you can't go to any real university
then
this is the college that you end up at
they love that one in michigan but
university of michigan that's a state
school too right
those are such weird schools like
university of michigan all right it's
a state school so anybody did a keg
stand instead of studying for math
goes in and they live in michigan you
end up there
that's why they're stadium that's why
the [ __ ] stadium is so big
you know 100 000 [ __ ] people
do you think it's because of football
programs is that good or because
that many people got a c in math in
michigan
that's my question for you but if you if
you you live out of state
it's like nine zillion dollars and you
got to be like a [ __ ] you know half a
physicist
to get in there and you know what's
funny i don't even know what a physicist
does
did they study physics oh look at that
over there is that a physicist
i don't know how would you know i'm a
physicist what's the deal
sorry the [ __ ] is it is that physics
are they the ones who study the inertia
um wow this is new level of ignorance
do you like that about this podcast that
rather than seeing me grow as a person
i'm i'm slowly regressing
you know maybe you were already ahead of
me maybe you were a couple steps behind
me
but now all of you you it's like i'm
that guy like it's a foot race right and
i came out of the track
out of the block sprinting you know now
i'm grabbing my sign you guys are just
going around me
you're still going to come in seventh
you're not winning a medal
but you beat me right
makes you feel better doesn't it what
does that say about you
when we come back we'll be talking um i
went for a bike ride
go ahead and laugh it's a great thing to
do trying to keep the weight down
you know because i read somewhere on the
internet
you know and it was typical research on
the internet where you have a question
and you're just like uh you know why is
the moon
round why is it round by the way
if it wasn't just a block out there what
would happen
oh jesus these 80s stand-up presence uh
presence premises that i'm just throwing
out here
that would probably still work in the
outer reaches of [ __ ] iowa
um any question you [ __ ] have
you go you you google it on the internet
and then immediately
you click on basically the first [ __ ]
website you find
you read it and you just take that as
law at least i do
that's what i do so one time i don't
know how i came across this but they
said basically every pound of fat
on your body is another five miles of
capillaries that you your heart has to
pump
which is why even just being five ten
pounds over
can significantly i did use that word
and i did pronounce it correctly
significantly that's five syllable word
everybody decrease
your lifespan you know
i mean how would you like it if every
day right you had to drive an extra five
ten miles to work that's probably not a
big deal but who's a pound overweight
you know who's two pounds overweight
after a certain age everybody's at least
15 pounds over right
what's 15 times five real quick that's
75 people
what if you had to go an extra 75 miles
to and from work every day what kind of
a [ __ ] mood would you be in
huh how much would your kids be running
for their lives when you came walking up
the door
up the path to the door that's what your
heart
is doing every time it beats when you're
that [ __ ] heavy
just that heavy then forget about these
ticket time bombs that'll walk around 30
pounds overweight
but they're still lifting weights dude
i'm all right you know touch my gut dude
it's [ __ ] solid
yeah it's because your fat your fat is
calcified
it's so entrenched there it has
squatters right right in front of your
stomach you dumb [ __ ]
i love fat people who sit they scare
[ __ ] fat and then they tell you how
[ __ ]
hard their stomach is and they think
it's like abs
it isn't it's the fat is [ __ ]
jammed in there so tightly like back in
the day when they used to pack people
into subways they used to that was
literally
a job your job was to [ __ ]
just lean in on the people and pack them
in
you know what i mean oh my god that was
the worst time
in society for claustrophobic people
slash the greatest time ever for
perverts
you know
it's just the entire spectrum complete
fear
to absolute ecstasy depending on who you
are
on that subway train but anyways that's
what it is so all you fatties out there
who sit there and your [ __ ]
stomach is harder than your head that's
not abs
that's not you like oh well you know i'm
so fat every time i do a sit up in bed
it's like i got a 45 pound
you know weight remember that you do
that back in the 80s
you put like it wasn't enough to do
setups you always had to add weight
if you're doing dips they had that [ __ ]
that literally looked like it was like a
[ __ ] metal tea bag hanging off of you
you put the chain around your waist and
then you'd hang weights off of that
dude he's [ __ ] doing dips with like
[ __ ] 225
hanging off his balls kid right all that
dumb [ __ ]
that's what that's what fat people i
think they think i know a lot of
fat people right now like why are you
always coming down on us i'll tell you
why because just kick a ginger date and
i've never seen a fat person come to my
rescue
you don't give a [ __ ] about me i don't
give a [ __ ] about you that's how it
works fatty
all right with your swollen feet
um
this is so unnecessarily mean right now
i don't know how i got onto this but i
have to see it through
because i got an hour to do here people
all right
the [ __ ] i was talking about packing oh
yeah yeah yeah so
i think these fat people with the hard
stomachs they feel like
when they just sit up in bed you know
and they make that noise as they go to
sit up and she's like
right they think that's like that's why
their stomach so hard
rather than it's just jam-packed with
syrup and nougat
and pancake batter and all that other
[ __ ] gooey [ __ ]
you know that they eat
i'll tell you right now i think they
should just get all those just get all
the fatties
and just get them out of the [ __ ]
country you know
you're bringing us down we've had it
we had it with your kind they should
stick all you fatties on a [ __ ]
island
i want to run for political office at a
very low level
preaching like like
what sounds like racism or nationalism
but it kind of affects everybody like
there's fat people in every
every race except the asians there's
very few asians every once in a while i
see a fat asian and you just know
he's hanging out with like americans you
know what i mean it's like there's no
way you got fat
eating that [ __ ] great diet that you
guys have over there i don't know what
it is over there but like
people are in [ __ ] shape in asia
you know i don't know about the russians
all that vodka that they're sucking down
um how many more people can i offend in
the first [ __ ] 10 minutes of this
podcast oh 12 minutes in okay that's
okay so i got a new 10 minutes to offend
people
um yeah i think they should
just run for office and just
just be like i get the fatties out of
town i get those [ __ ] people uh
those people you say hello and they
don't say hello back they just smile
and it's a fake smile i know i've talked
about this in my podcast there was
somebody when i lived in new york used
to do that
and i fell for it like the first 67
times i'd be walking down the hall
and this lady would be walking the other
way
with her [ __ ] kids and i always just
be i'd be like hey good morning or hey
after
you know hello or good afternoon
whatever the [ __ ] you say right big
[ __ ] wave hey
fellow human being being polite how are
you
right and she would always do the same
thing she tilt her head to the side like
she was going
oh and then she'd do this smile which
she she wouldn't show any teeth just
like the jay leno smile and then her
eyes would would like squint up like she
was looking into the sun
big stupid red lipstick and every
[ __ ] time i was just like oh what if
i just [ __ ] punched her right in the
face
made her kids cry and i just laughed i
didn't laugh
i just walked away you know
i'd still be affected there'd be a part
of my soul that i lost when i did it
but i'll tell you in that moment
and that catcher right as she closes her
eyes
you know like a [ __ ] old samuelson
move
don't even drop the glove keep it on and
just blast her right in the face
and i wanted to do that every [ __ ]
time
and then finally one day she walked
towards me and i was walking towards her
and uh she actually started to
anticipate
me saying hello because we're looking
right at each other and i'm in my head
just going i'm not saying anything i'm
saying hello to this [ __ ] says hello to
me
this is another thing that makes you die
early you know
is [ __ ] literally sitting in your
apartment your little ass
shoe box of apartment in new york
plotting
scheming conspiring ah you're gonna
[ __ ]
not say hello to this [ __ ] the next
time you see her you know
as you're eating a bacon egg and cheese
and adding an extra couple of miles so
you had to beat every couple of times
right so anyway she comes walking at me
i'm walking her i'm like i'm not [ __ ]
saying hello this time
you know and we got right to the point
where it's like who's gonna blink
and i timed it perfectly she anticipated
me saying hello and she started to tilt
her head
and i [ __ ] did my impression of what
she did
and i of course did it completely over
the top like i literally laid my head on
my shoulders squinted my eyes
and i made this ridiculous face and
continued to walk
and she never looked at me in the hall
again
and this is the genius of it she just
it's not like she knows what the [ __ ]
she looks like
i'm so self-involved i assume she
totally understood my point what i was
trying to make
you know like say hello stop making that
stupid face
she probably looked at like what the
[ __ ] is with that guy he has some sort
of mental tick
i don't want him around my children
but you know what it made me feel better
and you know what that's what this
podcast
is all about um hey people have you ever
heard of tivo
but where the hell you been will you get
you got your head up your ash
tivo's the greatest especially you know
really appreciate it
an old fella like myself you know why
because back in the day
back i got to explain this to you guys
back in the day when you missed
something you just
missed it it was over or at least on
if you if you didn't see it in the movie
theater that's it you missed it
there was no netflix there was no uh
something.com that you're watching on i
don't know it was over
you missed it evil knievel was gonna
jump over 20 buses
but for some reason your parents wanted
to take you to pewter pot to go get a
muffin
and you missed it and the next day you
were down at the bus stop and everyone
was talking about it and you were a man
without a country
and you knew eventually it was going to
come around to you and they were like
did you see it
and you were like no well you didn't see
it no i didn't see it i was getting
muffins with my parents and then just a
reign of book bags would just be
smashing you over the head and that's
what happened
but thankfully that never happens to
children anymore because of tevo
back in the day tv was weirdly hard to
watch you only watch a show at a certain
time and if you missed it or even part
of it you literally had to wait
for it to go into reruns before you
could see it again tevo has totally
changed all of that
and while other dvrs exist they're not
as awesome as tivo
you know why because if you have cable
cable tv lets you watch your shows
wherever you want with tivo stream
you can watch on your ipad all over your
house and even transfer your favorite
recordings
and take them with you on an airplane
waiting in line at the dmv
dentist office you can be sitting there
watching all of the sopranos
tevo makes uh other dvrs look like they
were designed by the soviet community
i like this copy only tivo reaches both
cable and web
to find any movie any show any video at
the press of a button
all right so there you go from the couch
to the kitchen from the minivan to 35
000 feet
tivo makes tv a hundred thousand times
better so why don't you do yourself a
huge favor and go get some
go get yourself some tivo have you heard
about that
tevo oh my god i want to get some
um all right let's do one other here
then we'll get back to a dollar shave
club everybody
how many times have you walked into cvs
and said hey i need uh the triple blade
plus
uh can i get one of those and they go
yeah that'll be 68
and you're like 68 dollars like yeah
that's why we keep it locked behind the
case here like it's some vintage guitar
rather than some piece of plastic with a
poor excuse for metal
to drag across your face that's going to
be useless in five days
you know probably end up floating around
the ocean poking out some porpoises eye
why is that thing so much money you know
why because it's a scam
well finally the cavalry is here when it
comes to shaving
um dollar shave club everybody getting a
good shave can be a real pain in the age
searching through 50 brands making new
blades
matching new blades to old handles
[ __ ] features where your razors
doubles as a flashlight a toothpick
etc 20 bucks for new razors to hell with
that go to dollarshaveclub.com
to get high quality razors delivered to
your door
for just a couple of bucks a month isn't
that great no longer
standing in line at those long lines at
cvs where you're behind anyone from a
doctor to some crack addict
waiting to get try to find the one
person working on the floor to unlock
the razors now they deliver them right
to you for a fraction of the cost
they've made it simple high quality
raises 100 guaranteed
sent on scheduled so you never have to
think about it again every month you get
a new pack
every week you change your blade and it
costs a fraction of what you pay at
retail
um you want to support this show go to
dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash bur or click on the dollar
shave
club banner on the podcast page at
billboard.com there you go
look at me look at me saving you money
saving you money
so it's been a hell of a week everybody
it's always been a hell of a week you
know if you try to stay up on world
events
there's always something crazy going on
right over in egypt
you know where the arab spring began as
far as i can remember
you know they elected a president and
within a year they're like you know what
we don't like this guy
why don't we have a new election and
then the new guy's like no no no i'm in
here
i'm in here i'm not leaving and they go
oh yeah we think you are
and he goes oh i don't think i am then i
bet you are now i bet i bet i don't
i bet i don't next you know there's
riots in the streets
you know when isn't it a hell of a week
sorry can you tell i'm searching for
something is where the [ __ ] is it
i swear to god i swear to god this is
the exact kind of thing that just slowly
[ __ ] drives me mad
about these goddamn [ __ ] computers
what did i do wrong this time
ghost of steve jobs can i watch this i'm
going to try to do this move
did it finally work did it finally work
oh here it is i got it i got it i got it
sorry
um what did i want to talk about oh i
know aaron hernandez everybody
you know what one of the whole [ __ ]
hilarious things
about aaron hernandez case is i'm
[ __ ] sitting here calling
up my buddies and people are so into
sports
in boston like the fact that somebody
lost their life that's like
that's like on page 19 of this story
i call my buddies back there and they're
all like dude now now what are we going
to do
you know gronk's always getting hurt
they traded [ __ ] welker
right who's brady gonna throw to
they don't they're not even thinking
like you know sports kind of takes a
back seat
to this unbelievably like bizarre
depressing sad horrific [ __ ] story
you know who gives a [ __ ] if we can beat
the dolphins or not
you know i don't know there's a big
there's a big pity party going on
in boston like oh my god this is like
the worst week ever well we had the
greatest decade ever
all right i stand by that anybody in any
state
in the united states if you want to
challenge the last 10 years of boston
sports
bring it on bring it on i want to know
one other [ __ ] city
that won all four of the major titles
numerous times
three super bowls two world series a
stanley cup and an nba championship
within 10 [ __ ] years
went to five super bowls two stanley cup
finals two nba finals
[ __ ] unbelievable all right and all
you guys now who are
gleeful and other in all your other
sports towns and you think you're gonna
[ __ ] bug me with your little [ __ ]
tweets
know that i know this you would cut off
your one of your [ __ ] sports watch
sport watching
balls to experience half the [ __ ]
success that boston had over the last 10
years you would take this week of horror
you would definitely trade it all right
you would do it you trade in your
[ __ ] mark sanchez
jersey dude i swear to god
jets fans would would take this week
just to [ __ ] make it back to the
super bowl
do you know the last time the jets were
in the super bowl we hadn't even
pretended to be on the moon yet
do you realize how long ago that was
you know richard nixon was still it was
a comeback story
he was like travolta and pulp fiction
that's how [ __ ] long ago it was
dude that's another thing they're going
to do what if he gets acquitted right
and then he [ __ ] signs with the jets
you know that was actually my thought
because i don't think as far as from
what i've seen unless his friends flip
on them
or unless they have some unbelievable
piece of evidence that they have not
introduced to the public yet
what you basically have is a mountain of
circumstantial evidence
against a mountain of money and as far
as
my little experience of watching the
court case the rich guy
walks he was just aaron hernandez
waiting for a bus
you know pimp my ride i'm driving a
piece of [ __ ] hey
exhibit can you put a [ __ ] fish tank
in the back of this thing right if he
was
something like that over
working in a warehouse unloading trucks
like oh billy redface back in the day
done you're going to jail all right but
you got you got you know
[ __ ] pro athlete money you can walk
you know some
lady on espn wrote the dumbest article
was saying that despite the fact of how
quickly er
the patriots acted once they found out
all these allegations against aaron
hernandez and released him
like this black mark will always
forever forever everybody forever will
stain the patriots
like if for some reason we don't steer
the planet into the sun in the next 300
years
there's going to be people 300 years
from now still talking about aaron
hernandez
still thinking about it every time they
see the patriot logo is that isn't the
dumbest thing
i've ever heard in my life you know
when you watch a carolina panthers game
when was the last time you thought about
ray carruth
you don't nobody remembers
nobody [ __ ] remembers this will be
something dude you know there was a guy
in the kansas city chiefs that
killed his whole family and then himself
after football
i don't know what maybe he got hit in
the head too many times i don't know
what happened
you know i never heard the story until
len dawson brought it up
it goes away do you know a guy
on the jets used to take his dick out
and imported the port authority he he
dyed his pubes green and he [ __ ]
shake his dick
um at people you know
and they were so shocked looking at his
green pubes they never it took the
longest time
before somebody finally looked at his
face and then they uh then they arrested
him and no one ever thinks about that
when they watch a jets game do they see
that's my point
you guys can look all this up this all
i know if you find the last one but the
other ones you'll find
oh jesus do what you think if they
turned pedroia
into a flanker they could give
culmination to him and that jesus freak
that could somehow
make up for hernandez going to jail
um all right
i don't even know what i'm talking about
right now to be honest with you hey this
weekend speaking of boston i'm gonna be
uh
i'm gonna be doing the cape cod melody
tent why how come why did i did i just
add a syllable to mel
mel all melody the cape cod melody tent
in hyannis is it in hyannis
somewhere down near the kennedy compound
they sit there spending all their
[ __ ]
booze money down there isn't that what
they did their prohibition money
their insider trading money um
i have no idea what the [ __ ] they did
all i know is they don't they have a big
yellow house
and they go out and they play touch
football that turns into tackle football
then it's this big family fight because
they're like a bunch of pitbulls
or if they [ __ ] that gene out of their
their family
at this point it's just all watered down
you know
too many weak men and women brought into
the fold
you know you ever think about that [ __ ]
like when people you know what's the
worst thing ever is when
somebody gives the son or daughter
of a father or mother that accomplished
something great
they always give the kid [ __ ] like it's
the kid's fault
like if you're the son of [ __ ]
michael jordan
or the daughter of amelia earhart
um people will always be like dude
you're not you're not as good as your
father blah blah they blame you
it's like it's not my fault that i'm
half cut with my mom
you know my dad can jump out of the gym
my mother trips over a mop handle every
[ __ ] three days
so i got fifty percent of that in me
weighing me down
i can still dunk but no i can't take off
from the foul line that's not my fault
it has nothing to do with my desire
or my heart or anything like that it has
to do with my mother and the same thing
with like amelia earhart's kid if she
had a kid
i don't know she probably didn't have a
kid no guy could handle that
back in the day when she was supposed to
be in the [ __ ]
kitchen making sugar cookies she's out
there flying around doing better than
the guys
that's why he has a dick safe i'm not
[ __ ] that her hair too short
right no guy could handle that i have no
idea did she have a kid
did she take him on the trip maybe
that's why she crashed you know
the kid was acting up she was reaching
back trying to slap him in the face like
how you could as a parent back then
and uh she went into the ocean who knows
who knows why these things happen
everybody i don't i don't pretend to
know
and you know what more importantly i
don't want to know but anyways back to
the
the boston sports things boston fans you
know not you're not all crying but the
ones who are bitching
i i don't want to [ __ ] hear it all
right
quit your [ __ ] crying and everyone
else in your other towns
try you enjoy this week as much as you
can because we've been kicking all your
[ __ ] asses for 10 years
and you know it's true at least mostly
true
you know the only people give a [ __ ] is
giants fans
that's just when it comes to football
right but some of them are yankee fans
and i'll take those two super bowl
losses for what we did to the yankees in
2004. i'll take that all day long
now there's one that will live forever
that
unlike the hernandez thing that will
live forever because
you know what's great about it there's
no way to beat it
there's no way to beat it and even
though team even the bruins lost four in
a row in hockey
right but we didn't have the level of
[ __ ]
hall of fame it's it's [ __ ] great
it'd be like if babe ruth lou gehrig
and you had dimaggio and mickey mantle
all in the same thing i know what you
guys are saying that's not true and i
say [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you in your pinstripe heart it's
true
the way you guys were loaded up with
free agents you couldn't do that back in
the day
back in the day you had to [ __ ] earn
it as opposed to now we can go out and
buy it los angeles lakers
you know anyways
i love how dwight howard dwight howard
leaves the lakers
and they're sitting there questioning
his heart and all that and never
once again never did they think well why
would you want to leave
why would you want to leave gee what
could it be the [ __ ] 800 pound
gorilla
how many great centers have to leave
town saying i really didn't have a good
[ __ ] time
playing with all what's his face over
there how many hall of fame coaches have
to write books
where if you read through the subtext
they're kind of going ah that guy's kind
of a [ __ ]
it's kind of a [ __ ] to be around you
know who says that about somebody they
won a championship with
you know this is my impression of a los
angeles laker fan as a parent
uh the kid comes home if that kid was
aaron hernandez and came home and
actually admitted to murdering two
people and then the third one
you know what the mother and father
would do they would stand up on the
coffee table and they would start
chanting mvp
[Laughter]
all right that might be admittedly
that's a little harsh
but i'm just saying i am uh
less than impressed with the average
knowledge of sports that a laker fan has
it's just [ __ ] dumb
i'm just dumbfounded dumbfounded that
not
not even once did you ever boo kobe
bryant when he walked off the court on
your whole [ __ ] team i just did
[ __ ] trying to think of a major city
that would put up with that
i don't know anyways maybe it's the sun
maybe it's the pot cookies i don't know
what
anyways all right here we go we got we
got some [ __ ] uh
we got some lettuce all right billy
beanbag
there's a new one billy bean from the
oakland a shh
billy bean bag i get it bean bag a uh
revolutionary chair dude how bad was a
bean bag for the environment when she
threw that thing out
it was made out of this this blend you
like when they blend like a scotch not a
scotch yeah
scotch is this guy i don't [ __ ] know
a whiskey it's a blend of wine where you
pour like a cabernet into a merlot
some real white trash [ __ ] this is like
that that this is the chair version of
that
it was like a pillow it was a chair
it was a fat person's stomach it was
everything right
it was food that astronauts ate out in
space
i think it was like filled with like i
don't know like
these little whatever the [ __ ] you call
those things one of those things that
coffee cups used to be made out of and
you'd sit there and scratch them
and let it go into the environment back
in the 70s before you realized that
birds were inhaling it and it was like
agent orange or
minor lung or something black lung is
that what it was
gee i don't know bill you're the one who
started riffing on bean bags and
realized that you didn't even know what
material it was made of styrofoam
they were filled with styrofoam and then
like the outside of it was like a blend
of like plastic
vinyl and uh you know
some sort of treated waste
and then you have the upscale ones where
they're actually made out of leather
and my dad we got a bunch of bean bags
and they were all plastic vinyl hunks of
[ __ ]
but his was a leather one and we just
think it was the [ __ ]
it's big [ __ ] and you'd grab it right
this is how you set up a bean bag you
grab it by the top like how your mother
used to pick you up by your hair
before she hit you with a wooden spoon
you know because you're watching
cartoons
um instead of doing your homework back
when you could hit children in public
or in your the safety of your own home
when you had company
you pick it up and you give it a shake
right and then you would just push it
right down the middle
then you'd sit on the [ __ ] thing and
it was horrifically
uncomfortable and it took a good five
years before people realized it
you know when people just bought them
because everybody else had them well
it's so
easy you can move them around the room
look how easy it is to vacuum under it i
can pick it up and
vacuum i see you can't do that with a
chair
um i wonder where all of those ended up
you know you know who gives a [ __ ] right
sitting here reminiscing about chairs
from the early 70s all right billy
beanbag
have you heard of justin carter this 19
year old kid
has been in jail since march for making
a sarcastic remark
here's an excerpt from a report
after a facebook friend with whom he
played video games described him as
crazy and messed up in the head
carter replied sarcastically one
imagines
uh oh yeah i'm really messed up in the
head
i'm going to shoot up a school full of
kids and eat
their still-beating hearts he added
l-o-l
and jk just kidding for good measure
for this he was arrested by austin
police
charged with making a terrorist threat
and thrown into prison
he may languish there until the start of
the next decade
get the [ __ ] out of here crazy stuff
bill this isn't russia
is this russia i know see dude this is
that snowden [ __ ] this is like all of
that we're just slowly
becoming this [ __ ] police state
you know what it is too people you got
to stop [ __ ] putting [ __ ] down in
print
that's just keep it how we we used to
say [ __ ] like that but we set it on the
playground
you know oh yeah like i'm gonna go shoot
the principal in the head that's what
you do you don't [ __ ] write it down
on the god
you know by the way was there any sort
of backlash against facebook for
basically ratting out all u.s
citizens you know turning us all into
the man man
you know he is still using facebook i
barely used it anyways
you know i still go there and i check
[ __ ] emails but in the back of my
head i'm like why am i using this guy's
[ __ ] [ __ ]
uh what do you call it social media
thing here
you know when he turned the [ __ ]
record how much money did he make
to turn and rat everybody out
you know i swear to god if you're one of
those [ __ ] people who's dumb enough
to be like well if you ain't a terrorist
uh
you know i don't you got nothing to
worry about yeah
i have no sympathy for you when i see
you in the fema camp with
me you know and that's what i'm gonna do
that's the only way that's gonna keep
the joy in my heart
is when i'm in the upper bunk and you're
in the lower bunk across the way i'm
just gonna for the rest of my
minutes on earth i'm just going to keep
looking at you going
out of terror what are you going to
worry about
over and [ __ ] over
until basically i'm beaten to death by
the other people in there who don't want
to hear it anymore
that creep me up um
i don't i don't know why this kid's
injured he's still in jail
uh i i don't know anything about it i
have to know you know
does he have a weird haircut and a
trench coat that freaked him out i mean
it is texas texas has always kind of
been their own deal
you know what i mean i mean they kill
people in texas the way they rescue dogs
here in l.a
so um i don't know how i feel about that
i mean as far as like population control
it's phenomenal but as far as their
swift uh
i don't know i just can't imagine
getting put to death for something you
didn't do
and you're walking down there uh like
how does that work in the afterlife when
you go to get judged
are you allowed to yell at god at that
point
like when he starts you know reviewing
your life you just stand there like dude
don't even [ __ ] start with me all
right just open the goddamn gates
already
okay you know how this story ends you
know everything right ooh
i know everything yeah you know
everything except how to get me out of
that
how come you how come you didn't help me
how come you you [ __ ] helped every
uh a bunch of people then you just
stopped talking to people
you know where hey hey let me finish
where was my burning bush
where was that well all right then
um hey here's some inspirational [ __ ]
here somebody wrote some inspiration
some inspiration for the monday morning
podcast
it says bill it's like that thing i read
on the internet once said
plant three rows of peas
peas of mind peas of heart peas
of soul i really hope nobody's eating as
i read the rest of this
plant three rows of squash
squash indifference squash
selfishness squash hate
oh jesus there's another one plant three
rows of lettuce
let us be kind let us
love one another let us grow
our own food
why all of that is great
and if everybody applied that the world
would be
such a wonderful place why does that
make you [ __ ]
you you grind your teeth to listen to
though
what it can you know that's a great
question you know at least i consider it
a great question
i'm in my own head here man sounded
awesome to me
seemed like a good thought and then i
said it and i was like wow how did i
come up with that one you guys might
disagree but
why is that who doesn't want peace of
mind piece of heart but you know why
because it's a [ __ ]
pun peas of mine
you know squash indifference
a lot of people don't know what
indifference means
and i i think i'm one of them
indifference means you have
like when somebody goes do you want this
you want that hey i'm indifferent
i think doesn't differently mean you you
don't you don't love it or hate it
you have absolutely no opinion on it
whatsoever
um it which like i don't know how to be
like that
i don't think anybody's indifferent
that's like that's like a higher level
of [ __ ] thought in my world
you know hey what do you think about
these drapes
like i immediately like you know they're
all right i like them
they're hideous i never just look at
something like what do you think about
this
i have no thought whatsoever
i don't know what that is what do you
think about this band yeah they're all
right
that's the closest i get to indifferent
you know bill why don't you look up the
[ __ ] word first before you make ah
this takes time [ __ ] reading
you know get a life
um speaking of rescuing dogs
i was out with the lovely nia the uh
yesterday
and we were driving around looking at
houses it's like something we like doing
um but it sucks because then you always
they're always better than your house
because you never go out and look at
houses that
are the same as yours you're like hey
let's go out look at [ __ ] we can't
afford
right and you go in the house like oh my
god this
is awesome and just with every house
you're just kind of going i live in a
[ __ ] tree fort
but it's still fun to do you know
and i feel like i'm actually helping the
owner of the house because
by going in there and i'm walking around
you know anybody else who's in there
they're thinking like oh [ __ ] this guy
might make an offer i got i got to jump
on this
you know that's how i justify me just
going in there and looking in people's
closets
um so anyways that's what we were doing
yesterday
and uh so what did we do we went so we
went to the grocery store
oh yeah to get some [ __ ] for dinner and
next door there was this place where
they had
uh you know rescue some dogs
so she's just like oh let's go over and
look at the dogs i don't want to go over
there
i don't go over there and look up like
some chewed up [ __ ] animal that's
gonna make me feel [ __ ] horrible
and i'll be laying in bed thinking about
the dog
like in no country for old man when the
dude's sitting there laying there and he
thinks about that guy that was asking
for water
and whatever he says like ah [ __ ] it
right you gotta go back there
the next thing you know you got some
psycho chasing you i mean i don't know
that's not gonna happen but
i'm just saying i'm gonna be thinking i
love dogs too much that i can't go down
and look at him because now i'm gonna be
just [ __ ] thinking about him
so she's like why
i could find fine just stop
doing that right so
we go over there
and we walk in and there's this [ __ ]
pitbull
that's like two weight classes up
from our dog big classic
[ __ ] beautiful pity head and i can't
even tell you what color this thing was
it was like um
it wasn't caramel it was like this
almost sandy kind of color
with no white or anything just no
patches just just that color
the [ __ ] dog was beautiful
and it had to weigh every bit of 80
pounds all muscle
and it was an absolute sweetheart like
you came in
and the thing is just [ __ ] doing that
thing where it's wagging its tail
so hard it looks like it's shaking its
ass and it's walking sideways as you
come up to it
and just buries that big head like right
in your lap
and then at one point i'm petting the
thing and it just [ __ ] just
leans into me like i was squat down like
a catcher petting it
and it wanted to be pet more so it just
sort of relaxed its body and leaned into
me and literally like knocked me over
and i fell down and then it went over
and started like licking my face was the
greatest [ __ ] i'm sitting this this all
basically happened in about 11 seconds
and then all of a sudden this lady comes
walking over
and the most annoying i'm talking to a
dog voice ever
just comes walking and goes
that's [ __ ] doing that and it was
like my eyes started watering
and i just [ __ ] stood up and walked
nia said something like okay and then
that happened she said something
loud enough that the girl heard but she
couldn't hear anything
and whatever the dog's name was like
franklin she's like
he just stood up and just [ __ ] walked
away
so now i'm over the other side of the
pet store buying [ __ ] bags
as uh michael rappaport called them back
in the day [ __ ] bags
um i [ __ ]
i'm buying those and within two seconds
this woman left with that dog
like walked in saw it and just left with
this 80 pound [ __ ] dog
and uh i had this such
mixed emotions like i was excited that
the dog got rescued
and i was bummed
that that was the person that rescued it
you know and i don't know why
she loved dogs the same way i did she
did a great thing like why should i be
bumped she just [ __ ]
you know what it was i wanted to keep
playing with the dog
you came in with your [ __ ] jerry
lewis voice from hell
did i just say from hell yes i did it's
the 80s comedy week
um all right what are we
uh are we 47 minutes in geez louise all
right let's continue on here
oh i started to mention that i went on
this bike ride by the way and uh for
those of you who
live out here in la or you coming to
visit
um you can actually ride a bicycle
all the way up to the hollywood side
and uh it is
one of the hardest bike rides i've ever
[ __ ] been on
you keep seeing the sign and every time
you go around a corner and you just
think this has to be the last [ __ ]
corner before i'm up here
you know and it just isn't and then it
isn't
and it isn't and he just keep [ __ ]
going and going and going it was like
the ascent to use a word that's beyond
my
vocabulary you already had to go all the
way up the canyon just get to the to the
beginning of like okay now we're going
to get to the summit here right
to use mountain climbing [ __ ] just that
a city
you already [ __ ] rode like a half
hour just to get up there and then this
ascent is i swear to god maybe
20 25 straight minutes of
i don't know what it is 45 degree angle
it's [ __ ]
brutal and then at some points
especially right at the end when
it gets even like 60 degrees it's
[ __ ] ridiculous
and uh i was beyond gasping for
wheezing i wrote and i stopped
right you know where they have the radio
antennas you're actually above the sign
got off the bike and grabbed the chain
link fence and was going
[Music]
for [ __ ] like five [ __ ] i thought
i was gonna pass out
um but you know what i probably knocked
off some miles on the capillaries there
um so anyways well you know what's great
as you're going up there's all these
guys dressed like lance armstrong coming
down and they all give you words of
encouragement because they just did it
you know and i'm going up there
on a mountain bike made for a lady it's
the one i got for nia that she never
[ __ ] rode
and uh i love riding women's bicycles
you know like women's bicycles that
designed
the way guys bicycles should be
it i always thought they had that
reverse well basically they shouldn't
bang that [ __ ] on something metal
although knowing those psychos they
probably [ __ ] enjoy it you know
um harder um
the way the woman's bicycle is [ __ ]
like they're so concerned about their
dresses and you looking up and seeing
their clam
that once again seeing their clam
is is you know hiding that clam is more
important
than somebody else's smash testies
um i go up there it's not like the old
school schwinn one went all the way down
to like your ankles but it's
angled to the point where i can get my
feet down and
uh oh ricky ricky bobby are going to be
okay
you know so i don't have a problem with
it i have sort of a
uh an androgynous
bike that i ride you know it's a
mountain bike but it's not a guy's bike
and it's not a woman's bike it's kind of
it's you know it's a little questionable
don't
i the don't ask don't tell huffy
that i ride um and i'm not gonna
apologize for it
you know i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about all right got my ass
kicked
bill i'll keep this short and sweet
because i know how bad you are at
reading things
you know i can't even argue that uh he
goes i live in a small city
roughly 90 000 people what do you live
in china
what's that a little village to you 90
000 [ __ ] people
that's gigantic the nightlife district
of the city
has more or less 10 different buzz or
clubs
i by the way before people are dicks to
me on the internet i mean that's that's
gigantic if you say that you you live in
a small town
i guess a small see said city
all right you're right i'm an [ __ ]
okay here we go the nightlife district
of the city
has more or less 10 different bars or
clubs
well how big are they if there's 90 000
people in there you got to think at
least half of them drink
10 bars or clubs get 4 500 people in
each one that doesn't make any sense
uh last weekend i left all my friends at
one bar to go meet up with the girl at
another
while there i was heavily intoxicated
and grabbed the lady's ass i was meeting
apparently two drunk guys didn't take
too kindly to this
and decided to attack me and gave me a
good beating
somehow i think you left some some
details
did you grab the ass of the woman you
were talking to
um were that her two older brothers and
you were too hammered to realize it
anyways he goes it's hard to show my
face back in this club again
after i got beat up should i just man up
and go in
again next weekend like i own the joint
and if i see the two guys should i get
my group to give them a good ass kicking
along with me
jesus christ dude um
all right first of all you got you
didn't it's like you lost to one guy you
lost to two people
you know so i don't think that's a
uh i think the embarrassing thing is
that you grabbed a woman's ass
i need to know more details about that
so let's just say
that these two guys were jealous because
they wanted to [ __ ] her and you came in
um something was going on somehow they
were connected
to that woman all right well here's the
first lesson
all right if you're going into a bar to
meet some lady
some strange lady that you don't have a
relationship with
you know that's to use my analogy last
week that's an away game
okay would you go into the bleachers
wearing the other team's [ __ ] jersey
by yourself you need you need next time
you go in there you need to bring some
friends
um i think you're just going in there
and you're asking for trouble and
uh one way or the other that you go back
in there with some friends
you're gonna end up in uh either jail or
the hospital
one or the other that's it either way
you're gonna end up in court either
suing because you don't have a [ __ ]
you know you got a droopy eye now or
just it's just
you don't want to do that you don't all
right you went in there you were drunk
you know what dude this is really on you
this is on you
uh you were careless with yourself i'm
gonna blame you the way they used to
blame rape victims back in the day
all right you weren't dressed like a
[ __ ] but you you were doing the
dressing like a [ __ ] version for
being a guy you walked in there all
sloppy
you walked into somebody else's bar you
grabbed one of their women
you started squeezing her ass like you
were testing out some shaman
right and then you got beat down this
should be a life lesson for you
all right if you're gonna do some donnie
brosko
bar [ __ ] you gotta you gotta have you
gotta have a crew with you
and you have to be sober and uh
don't grab her ass until you talk her
into [ __ ]
till you're back in her apartment that's
when you do the ass grabbing
do not go into do not go into a bar
especially you know within a it's a
division rivalry you know what i mean
like as a patriots fan you would never
go down on the metal lens and start
grabbing some
jets chicks ass that's it you're gonna
get a hibachi over your [ __ ] head and
vice versa
if i see versa there so there you go
there's your advice
revenge uh that that's not that's not
you don't want to do you don't want to
do that that's
it's just going to escalate and then
what do you think's going to happen
you're going to go down there and kick
their ass and it'll be like all right i
guess it's even
then they get then they go out and get a
bigger crew and they gotta top your ass
kicking
and by then you know it's like anchorman
you're in that alley fight
right and then brick kill somebody
all right next one so i yeah sorry i
wouldn't go back to that all right just
take the ass kicking it's a funny
[ __ ] story
just tell it in a colorful way and leave
it at that as a [ __ ] idiot i walked
into somebody else's bar hammered by
myself i start grabbing this girl's ass
and next thing you know i'm admiring the
uh the woodworking
of the floor like wow look at this is is
this a
brass rail that you you know footstep
how do they keep it so shiny
you know as you're laying there on your
side
watching them kicking you in the kidney
you're looking in the refr
the the reflection of that brass rail
all right bill we got it you're on the
floor popcorn in your hair
there's a million ways to tell that
story sir don't go back down there
you don't want to do that all right uh
hey billy bin laden there's another one
another good one
uh imagine if you started using a puppet
to mix things up
oh for my act all right you know
the same way dylan went electric you
could lose a few fans but you'd own the
midwest and central florida
dude do you realize how [ __ ] funny
this is this is this written by another
comedian
to have that sort of insight do you know
how [ __ ] true that is
if i stop doing if i kept doing jokes
but i introduced a puppet i already know
what i would do
i thought about it a long time ago if i
ever used a puppet what i would do
is forever the puppet is always smarter
than the puppeteer
i would just stand there berating the
puppet
and i keep telling it to shut the [ __ ]
up all right you don't say anything you
don't even [ __ ] think
unless i come up to thoughts how [ __ ]
dare you start giving me [ __ ] with your
little feet
go [ __ ] yourself that's how i would do
it as opposed to having a puppet
giving me [ __ ] and then i'm rolling my
eyes you know like the husband on a
sitcom like well my wife is smarter than
me i'm just the dumb
fat guy right um
anyways he goes here's the thing you'd
probably be hilarious despite the
ridiculous
ridiculousness of it all you'd lose your
mind too
being up there every night having a
conversation with yourself constantly
feeding
an unhealthy mental state well that's
kind of what i do on the podcast here
sir
uh he goes i guess i should ask a
question
so what would your puppet look like
would he wear
overalls or a suit would he be an animal
or would he even be a he it was a female
puppet you could give it noogies every
time she was acting up yeah see you
yeah see the direction you're going
that's the only way to go now
with the puppeteering or whatever you
call being a ventriloquist act is just
it's just so
gone in that direction where the [ __ ]
puppet's smarter than you
you know you know it's funny someone's
gonna steal this idea they'll be
absolutely
brilliant taking an old genre and
turning it on it's
you know what's funny somebody's
probably already done it
is i just in a roundabout way just said
i had a brilliant idea do you like that
are you still sitting here are you
nauseous at this point
um no that's what i would do and then
what i would do is i would team up with
the dummy and i would start trashing
people
in the audience you know although you
know something
uh i don't know
i have i you know you're talking about
puppets here i don't know
where to go with that um
where do we go from here let's let's oh
i gotta read i gotta read a little more
advertising here everybody
we got to keep the lights on here ah
where the [ __ ] is it
there's all the capitals in [ __ ]
europe okay we got that one you know you
think i would be smart enough one of
these [ __ ] weeks to just have the
only things open the things that i need
but i don't i have everything up here
i'm looking at ebay
and some old ludwig bass drum all right
here we go
here we go happy holidays
all right evoice everybody having your
own receptionist would be great
but paying their salary is really
expensive that's why thousands and
thousands of entrepreneurs are now using
e-voice to enhance their image
work faster and make more money you can
try e-voice right now for free
when you go to evoice dot com user use
the promo code bill
with e-voice as your virtual assistant
you get your own toll-free number
and dial by name directory all your
calls will be professionally answered
and routed wherever you want
e-voice even types all your voicemail
messages and emails
emails them to you instantly just like
with the real receptionist but without
the high cost
with e-voice your toll-free number and
virtual assistants start at 10 bucks a
month that's it
you can operate like a top executive but
stay lean like a startup
and blow away your competition e-voice
has been mentioned
as a key tool for today's businesses in
both
inc magazine and forbes so you know it's
good i believe in e-voice and i want you
to try it for free right now for 30 days
go to
go to evoice dot com promo code bill
that's evoice dot com promo code bill or
just go to the podcast page at
billbird.com and click on the e-voice
banner right now
all right and the all-time classic
stamps.com everybody
you have to know this one by heart if
you're still going to the post office
why are you i'm going to read this one
for the last guy in [ __ ] bulgaria
that doesn't know you don't have to go
to the post office anymore
do they have the post office over there
in bulgaria
huh capital sophia
isn't that right oh jesus he's worldly
he knows a couple of capitals there
stamps.com there's nothing instant about
going to the
getting postage from the post office
driving there parking it's a waste of
time
so use stamps.com instead instantly get
postage for any letter
or package right from your desk
stamps.com is so quick and easy to use
that even a dummy like me can use it buy
and print official us postage using your
own computer and printer
stamps.com will send you a digital scale
that automatically calculates the exact
postage you need
they'll even help you decide the best
class of mail based on your
needs no guesswork plus it's convenient
take care of your mailing and shipping
wherever you need to 24 7 right from
your own desk you'll never have to go to
the post office again
i use stamps.com to send out all my dvds
i've never had a problem with it
uh right now use my last name bur
b-u-r-r for a special offer
no risk trial plus 110 bonus including a
digital scale
and up to 55 dollars free postage
all right don't wait go to stamps.com
now before you do anything else click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page and type burr that's stamps.com and
enter burr
and finally the last one
hulu plus everybody you've tried
streaming hit shows on your pc on
hulu.com now it's time to try your free
trial
of exclusive content in your living room
on your mobile devices
on hulu plus with hulu plus you get
total control to watch thousands of
uh tv shows wherever wherever you want
whenever you want use hulu plus on
connected tvs game souls
game consoles sorry blu-ray players roku
apple tv pc or watch from anywhere on
your smartphone
or tablet on demand at all time
uh all times and with hulu plus you can
binge on full seasons
watch your favorite current shows and
even full series runs of classic tv
shows it's endless
they've got community modern family
south park snl jimmy kimmel family guy
and more
hula plus is only 79 799 799
per month but right now they're offering
an extended free trial of hulu plus
that is only available to podcast
listeners take control of your tv
watching experience go to the podcast
page at billbert.com
click the hulu plus banner for your
extended free trial or go to
huluplus.com
bill all right there you go a couple of
options there on how to watch tv this
week
um all right let's go back to the
lettuce
um all right push over hey bill
i need some standing up for myself
i need some help standing up for myself
i live with my mom as a kid and she used
to tell me how bad of a father my dad
was and i would say i never wanted to be
like my dad as i got older i became
every everyone's [ __ ]
all they would have to say was you're
just like your father and i would do
whatever they told me to do
it wasn't just my mom and my sister a
lot of my friends pushed me aside too
i've since moved out i'm 23 now but
people still walk all over me and i'm
overly nice to everyone
how do i stop being everyone's doormat
ah jesus dude
you're describing me when i was 23.
everybody liked me
i was nice i if i met you for [ __ ]
two minutes
and you asked me to help you move and to
use my truck i'd let you
you know and then when you went to pay
me i'd be like no no
no no no i'm okay uh
you got to start you guys got to start
doing it um
and this is the thing it's a learning
curve all right
where it's like you can't just be like
i'm going to start sticking up for
myself
and then the next time you're in a
moment where you're supposed to stick up
for yourself and you don't you can't
consider that a failure because you'll
at least be conscious
you're going to you've got to go through
that torturous period
where you're now watching yourself
getting walked all over and you're going
well here's that situation again
and here i am not sticking up for myself
which will cause you
in the short run to be even more down on
yourself
because before when it was happening you
were so busy trying to get the other
person
to like you you weren't focusing on what
a [ __ ] you were being
now you're actually going to watch it
all right
but know that that's part of the uh road
to success
any time you're trying to break a bad
habit you know you're trying to quit
drinking
or you're trying to stop eating late
night and here you are eating again
you're beating yourself up as you're
[ __ ] doing it
that's the first steps because before
you didn't you'd just be shot getting b
shotgun and beers right eating ice cream
and not even questioning it
so with this [ __ ] um
what can really help you out is if you
write it down
write down like listen i'm tired of
people telling me that i'm just like my
dad
um you know
and you know you could start with that
don't tolerate that anymore
just say to your mother i want you to
stop saying that to me
because all you've done is tell me how
bad of a father my dad is and so
whenever you tell me that that's like
you're
saying that i'm a piece of [ __ ] all
right
i'm 23 now it's time for me to become my
own man i don't
like when you tell me that it hurts me
as a person it hurts my development
all right now how can your mother say no
to that
you know easily she could be a [ __ ]
pain in the ass but i don't know
um but just just start writing down like
you know
i don't know it's like doing like
starting out comedy you don't
[ __ ] go up on stage trying to do an
hour and kill you just try to hang in
there for five minutes
so just just take baby steps and uh
my biggest thing the reason why i
wouldn't i avoided confrontation is
because the only way
confrontation when i grew up was
screaming [ __ ] you and getting into a
fist fight
so you know when i would be down at
whatever bringing my
truck in to get it fixed and it felt
like i was getting [ __ ] over
i would be in my head literally going
like i don't want to fight this guy you
know even if i win i'm going to have
grease all over my face
if he gets a couple of shots in you know
it's probably going to grab a wrench
like i'm literally thinking that
when all i'm doing is is getting a
tune-up
and i feel like you know or you know i
mean one time the guy put a new new
engine in my truck
i remember uh it just died
the thing died and i i wanted to make it
as a comic and the last thing i needed
was a car
payment so it's like i would either go
out back then you could get a piece of
[ __ ] for 11 grand
i'd either have be 11 grand in debt or
like you know get a new engine put in
was like you know
12 1500 bucks fellas like yeah why don't
we knock a zero off of that
so that's what i did and i paid the guy
and the [ __ ] [ __ ]
charged me for the antifreeze that he
put in the engine he just would charge
me for everything i learned a lot never
never uh never trust a mechanic that has
a manicure
and that's not a joke he had cologne his
[ __ ] nails
were like pimp level shiny
so um but i didn't say anything to him
because i'm like oh this guy's like you
know he's like 60. i don't i'm not going
to punch a 60 year old guy in the
like and i would be thinking this [ __ ]
but i wasn't even
conscious because it just been in my
head
since i could remember so it's playing
on a loop and a lot of [ __ ] if you
finally say it out loud or you write it
down
you realize how wrong it is or how
absurd it is
and it can it can kind of kick-start you
to uh
start going down the right road so that
that's what i would do and you have to
be very forgiving of yourself
like you know what's funny is you're a
total pushover probably until it comes
to looking at yourself then you're
probably like a [ __ ] drill sergeant
and you're always beating yourself up so
i would say
you know trying to find the humor in in
breaking a bad habit
or trying to change yourself and uh
you know you work at it every day you
know it's like playing an instrument you
know if you play once every three months
you're never gonna get better but if you
[ __ ] play an hour every day
all of a sudden right you start
shredding and here come the girls and
they're jumping on your dick
right you start sticking up for yourself
you start they they the women they
they they're attracted to that i'm not
talking about being a dick but
women are attracted to [ __ ]
like guys who they don't want to marry
some [ __ ]
right all of them want you to go
out there and [ __ ] grab it by the
throat
and drag it home and throw it in the pot
so they can [ __ ] cook it up
metaphorically speaking last thing i
ever want to do is suggest that a woman
would want to go into a kitchen
and actually be [ __ ] nice for once
and make that guy a goddamn sandwich
um sorry
uh you know what i'm saying all right i
hope that helped you out
um did i get everything i get to
everything here oh cop that shot
dog bill what's your take on the
hawthorne police officer firing off
one into a dog [ __ ] [ __ ] right
well i mean obviously
i'm not pro shooting dogs but i wasn't
there
i don't know what happened look if
you're a cop and you're walking in there
and some giant dog comes at you with his
teeth showing
and is gonna [ __ ] maul your face off
you know i mean what are you supposed to
do but if if that [ __ ] that i mean i've
seen youtube videos where like the dog
isn't doing it's just barking like
because you're in the house but it's not
charging it's not doing anything and
they have
it's standard procedure eliminate the
threat and they just [ __ ] shoot the
dog that brutal
there's a brutal one on youtube where
they went into the wrong [ __ ] house
and they got the guy on the floor and
then they shoot his dog and they realize
they're in the wrong house and they
killed both his dogs
it's brutal it's brutal but um
in defense of the cops those are the
ones that people put up on youtube
you know i imagine that they could then
show you a thousand
of cops going in getting attacked by
once
great dogs that their piece of [ __ ]
scumbag owner turn into a maniac
so maybe there's some sort of sweeping
thing that if the dog
weighs more than [ __ ] if you feel
threatened by the dog
um i'm just playing devil's advocate
here you're a cop you're going in to
arrest somebody they you're
you're trying to deal with does is this
person gonna pull a weapon
out and blow my [ __ ] brains out i'm
never gonna see my kid again and
meanwhile you got
this dog you know what i mean
it's like you can only look at one thing
at one time so and your life is in
[ __ ] danger i think a lot of people
including animal lovers
uh we've thrusted it's i think it's very
easy
to not be a cop and just sit there and
you do you know what i would have done
the same way you do like you know
when you trash the quarterback of your
team you know what i would have done
with my non-athletic ass this is what i
would have done i would have left the
left over the [ __ ] defensive line
you know and then called an option or
whatever the [ __ ] you would have done so
yeah i mean just hearing that story uh
absolutely devastating because i know if
the cops ever came in my house my dog
would be flipping out and trying to
attack them
and i would be like let me just put her
in the other room but if they
whatever were coming in there and i was
considered a threat they have to take me
down and then my dog would come at him
and then they would [ __ ] shoot my dog
um and it would suck
so i'm obviously i wish there was a
some way that they wouldn't have to do
that
uh but as much as people 100
blame cops there uh the real
culprit that set that whole thing off
are [ __ ] [ __ ]
who turn their dogs into maniacs and
maybe even someone like myself who
doesn't i mean i don't know how to have
my dog under control
so i just put her in the back room
because i don't know because some
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] her up
you know ah jesus christ i got work to
do
um so there you go that is the uh you
know i didn't even get
to that [ __ ] you see that reporter
that died
let me get to where the hell is that
story here
this writer for rolling stone which i
have a subscription to
one of the magazines few magazines that
i actually read
every episode every installment um
michael hastings uh
he had a horrible death he [ __ ] was
going down i believe it was highland
just south of melrose
his mercedes was traveling at ridiculous
speeds he hit a
[ __ ] tree and the whole thing
exploded bursted into flames and he had
to identify him by his dental records
and uh allegedly this guy knew
i guess he wrote some [ __ ] article in
rolling stone where he was over in
afghanistan talking to some higher-ups
in the military and they were saying
some [ __ ] that they thought was off the
record and he put it all in the article
and there's people conspiracy theorists
trying to say that his car
was cyber attacked now i'm not even
gonna get into that
but dude how [ __ ] up is the world
getting if
like that's actually something that
somebody could do
i'm not saying whether it was done by
this guy or not i have no [ __ ] idea
he might have been hammered
i have no idea i have no [ __ ] clue i
don't know anything about it but i'm
just saying that
the fact that somebody could hack into
your computer
and cause your car to speed up
and there's nothing you can't shut the
car off
this is why i don't know i don't believe
that it's just like as evil as that is
we got to eliminate this guy
isn't there a zillion other ways to kill
him without doing that
like what if he slammed into like a
[ __ ] minivan
with a you know a married couple and
their three four kids
you know there's got to be you know
can't they just spray some mist on them
you know just walk up to him in a mall
like hi sir would you like to try this
fragrance you just spray it on them and
then the guy like you know
10 minutes later he's trying on some
slacks he just keels over you can't just
do it that way
but anyways is this true is can they
actually do that [ __ ] and this makes me
feel glad that you know half my time out
here i drive around in a classic car
you know because not like i'm any sort
of a threat but what i'm saying is if
that
i just would think if you had the
ability to do that some [ __ ] nerds
would just do it just to do it because
it would be funny just speed you up for
a second and slow you down just to freak
you out
you know like do you remember back in
the day when
this is like pre-internet fun what you
would do is you'd take your garage door
opener
right and you would drive around the
neighborhood and you'd point it at every
garage until you found somebody that had
the same one as you
and back in the day they just had a like
it wasn't sophisticated
so not only yours opened not only yours
it opened the other ones too
so you'd you'd eventually
find somebody that had the same garage
door
brand as you and you could open and
close their garage
so at least you could in my [ __ ]
neighborhood so you just find you just
drive one person nuts you just drive by
and you just [ __ ] every once in a
while would just open it and
i don't know why we would do it we were
[ __ ] but
so using that if you could [ __ ] do
that
um with cars wouldn't wouldn't
like these people like you know hack in
to steal like credit card
numbers and [ __ ] i mean wouldn't there
be somebody just doing that just to do
it like you're bored
it was this the was this the dumbest
part of the podcast everybody did i
stick the landing starting off with
ignorance
and then uh well why wouldn't they well
[ __ ]
you know what it the reality if i ever
book a commercial i'm gonna be
you know that commercial where the adult
sits there with all the kids
and they go you know what would you what
would you do if you had a zillion
dollars and
the kids like to buy ah they made out of
candy
yeah we could have hot fudge waterfalls
and [ __ ]
i would be sitting there right with them
except it wouldn't be like the
basketball one where they were like
making fun of the fact like i would be
like you know what i'm saying i'm saying
i'm more on everybody all right well
that's the podcast for this week
i hope it made you feel better about
yourself at least your intellect
um i am going to be as i mentioned i'm
going to be at the
cape cod melody tent on friday saturday
i'm at the hampton beach ballroom casino
and then sunday i'm in down newport
rhode island at the newport yachting
center
all right two tents in an attic that's
what i'm playing this weekend i can't
[ __ ] wait
um i always play hampton in newport i've
never played the cape cod melody tent
and this is where uh
the one and only time i ever saw george
carlin so this is a very special uh
gig for me and there's still a few
tickets left
i'd love for you to come down there and
uh
share that experience with me and blah
blah blah
all right okay so here's the outro
everybody um
all right now that the show's over don't
forget to support all the sponsors
a quick recap uh join the thousand
entrepreneurs who use e-voice
as their personal receptionist um hulu
plus
you want to start watching favor your
favorite hit tv shows right now
you all of that shit's on the podcast
page and finally
dollar shave club there's no reason to
pay all that money everybody
they're going to send you blades every
month you use one a week nice fresh
shave uh your side of your face smooth
as a baby's ass
all right that's it everybody that's a
podcast for this week go [ __ ] yourselves
as always
thank you for all the emails um
and uh thanks to everybody who's been
coming out to my shows and thanks to
everybody who went out and saw the heat
again this weekend
i believe it came in third place and uh
it's made a bunch of [ __ ] money and
uh
seriously thank you for going out there
and thank you for all the kind words
everybody is uh
said um to me about
the stuff that i did in the movie it
meant a lot to me all right that's it go
[ __ ] yourselves we'll talk to you next
week